Mein Name ist Ucak, ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich Doktor.
Danke, bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, okay?
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Irene Lange.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam buchstabieren?
Ida, Richard, Emil, Nordpol, Emil. Mein Name und mein Vorname, Nachname Ludwig Anton Nordpol Gustav Emil Lange.
Frau Lange, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 76 Jahre alt Doktor.
76 Jahre alt, okay. Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
5. Mai 1949.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1 Meter 76.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie zuzeit?
71 Kilogramm.
Danke für die Informationen Frau Lange. Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie im Moment?
Ja Doktor, ich bin heute hier, weil ich Bauchschmerzen habe.
Wissen Sie, heute ist Operfest und wir haben unsere Gäste, unsere Hause sitzen und ich hatte plötzlich Bauchschmerzen.
Okay, also ich gratuliere Ihnen Frau Lange beim Fest und ich möchte fragen, seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Seit 3 Tagen Doktor.
Okay, wo genau sind diese Schmerzen lokalisiert? Ich meine Oberbauch, Unterbauch?
Die Schmerzen sind im linken Unterbauch Doktor.
Okay, können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben? Also sind sie eher drückend, dumpf, stechend?
Ja, die Schmerzen sind steckend, drückend und dumpf. Aber ich habe sehr starke Schmerzen Doktor.
Können Sie mir eine Schmerzmittel geben oder?
Frau Lange darf ich fragen, wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzstelle von 1 bis 10?
Ja, ich denke 8 Doktor. 8, 9, 8, 8.
Ja, Sie haben recht, das ist eine starke Schmerzen. Also ich möchte wissen, ob Sie eine Allergie gegen irgendwelche Medikamente haben Frau Lange?
Medikamente? Ich keine Allergie gegen Medikamente Doktor.
Okay, Schwester Müller, bitte geben Sie den Patienten einen Spasmolythika und einen Magenschutz.
Frau Lange, wir haben Ihnen ein paar Medikamente verabreicht. Fühlen Sie sich jetzt besser?
Ja, ja Doktor, ich fühle mich jetzt sehr besser, danke schön.
Okay, sehr gerne. Bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid, wenn Sie ein Medikament benötigen, okay?
Danke schön.
Gerne. Und Frau Lange, strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwohin aus?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt. Ich habe immer linke Seite Bauchschmerzen.
Diese Schmerzen sind plötzlich aufgetreten und haben sich diese Schmerzen im Verlauf der Zeit verändert? Ich meine schlimmer geworden, besser geworden?
Die Schmerzen sind im Verlauf der Zeit immer schlimmer geworden.
Okay, haben Sie früher eine Ähnliches Beschwerden gehabt?
Früher? Ja, vor einem halben Jahr hatte ich eine Ähnliches Beschwerden, Doktor.
Ein und halb Jahr?
Ja, vor einem halben Jahr.
Okay, und waren Sie damals beim anderen Arzt gewesen?
Ja, ich habe viele Mal bei unserem Arzt gegangen. Er hat mir gesagt, ich habe keine besonderen Krankheiten.
Er hat mir ein paar Magenschutz-Tabletten, Tassel und Schmerzmittel gegeben, aber es war nicht geholfen mir, Doktor.
Okay, also momentan, ich meine seit drei Tagen, haben Sie gegen diese Schmerzen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Ja, ich habe ein Magenschutz-Tablet genommen, aber es war mir nicht geholfen, nicht geholfen gebracht.
Okay, also Tassel haben Sie eingenommen? Ja.
Okay, alles klar. Aber keine bestimmte Diagnose wurde gestellt?
Ja, leider Doktor.
Okay, alles klar. Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert oder verschlimmert?
Ja, ich denke seit drei Tagen immer verschlimmert.
Und gibt es etwas Beschützendes, etwas? Körperhaltung oder Essen oder Stress?
Ja, ich verstehe Doktor. Wenn ich mich nach vorne beuge, wird es etwas besser.
Okay, ich verstehe. Frau Lange, leiden Sie unter Luftnot oder Husten?
Luftnot, Husten? Nein. Aber ich habe Fieber, ja.
Okay, das war meine nächste Frage. Okay, haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Ja, ich habe gemessen. Das Fieber ist 38,9.
Wo haben Sie das Fieber gemessen? Ich meine im Mund oder in der Achselhöhle?
Achselhöhle Doktor, ja.
Haben Sie Schüterfrost oder Nachschweiß?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Okay, ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie erbrechen?
Ja Doktor, ich habe Übelkeit, ja. Und Doktor sagt heute Morgen Schmerzen bei Wasser lassen, ja.
Ich habe Schmerzen bei Wasser lassen, ja.
Also wie oft gehen Sie auf die Toilette, ich meine zum Wasser lassen? Frau Lange?
Ich habe seit morgen 3 Mal, ja.
Kleine Menge oder ganz normal?
Ganz normal.
Okay, haben Sie Blut im Urin bemerkt?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, nein.
Okay, mussten Sie erbrechen Frau Lange?
Erbrechen jetzt nicht.
Okay, alles klar. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Wegen dieser Wäsche habe ich kaum Appetit Doktor.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit unwirklich ab oder zu genommen?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt. Ich denke, ich bin immer gleichgewischt.
Das freut mich. Schlafen Sie gut?
Deswegen diese Wäsche habe ich nicht gut Doktor.
Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Durchzuschlafen, ja.
Okay, sind Sie vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Covid-Infektionen geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig. Ich bin gegen alles vollständig geimpft Doktor.
Super. Frau Lange, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte,
wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, ich habe seit 10 Jahren Bluthochdruck Doktor.
Und nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ja, ich nehme dagegen NL April und Lersanipidin.
Aber ich habe NL April und Lersanipidin.
Und wie oft nehmen Sie diese Medikamente ein?
Einmal täglich, morgen.
NL April oder Lersanipidin?
Beide.
Okay. Haben Sie eine Medikamentenliste dabei?
Ja, aber jetzt nicht dabei. Die Liste ist in meiner Haustür, Doktor.
Okay. Frau Lange, wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Meine Hausärztin heißt Frau Schmid.
Okay. Also machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen. Ich werde Ihren Frauenärztin kontaktieren über diese Details, ja?
Okay, gerne. Sonst noch etwas? Bluthochdruck?
Ja, Doktor. Außerdem habe ich seit zwei Jahren Zuckerkrankheit, ja.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ich nehme dagegen Metformin Tablete ein, ja.
Kennen Sie die Dosierung?
Ja, 870 mg.
870 mg?
Ja, 870 mg. Nein, 750 mg. Entschuldigung.
Okay, 150 mg?
Ja.
Und morgens?
Ja, morgens. Einmal. Täglich.
Okay. Sonst?
Das war es.
Okay, nehmen Sie...
Ja, ja, Entschuldigung. Ich habe seit 1987 Arthrose im rechten Knie und nehme bei Bedarf Ibuprofen, ja.
Kennen Sie die Dosierung?
Jetzt nicht.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig mit der bei Bedarf irgendwelche anderen Medikamente außer genannten ein?
Nein.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden, so lange?
Ja, mit 15 Jahren wurde mein Mandel empfangen, Doktor.
Okay, sonst etwas?
Sonst 1987 wurde mein Kreuzband rechts operiert. Und 1994 hatte ich eine unkomplizierte Entfernung eines Knotens in der Brust, ja.
Welche Seite?
Rechts.
Okay.
Sind Sie allergisch gegen irgendwelche Medikamente, Nahrungsmittel, Pflanzen?
Ja, ich habe Allergisch gegen Katzehalle.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Das äußert sich Yukreis und Hautausschlag.
Okay. Sonst noch etwas?
Ich habe keine anderen Allergien, Doktor.
Okay. Frau, geraten Sie?
Leider. Aber jetzt nicht.
Ich bin seit 6 und 2, 76 Jahren nicht Raucherin. Aber ich habe davor etwa 30 Jahre ungefähr 15 Zigaretten am Tag geraucht.
Okay, wenn ich alles richtig verstanden habe, Sie rauchen seit 26 Jahren nicht mehr?
Ja, ja.
Und Sie haben 15 Zigaretten täglich 30 Jahre lang geraucht?
Ja, richtig.
Okay. Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, Alkohol trinke ich kaum, nur gelegentlich ein Glas Rotwein am Wochenende.
Okay. Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Drogen nehme ich keine, Doktor. Nein.
Okay, das freut mich. Frau Lange, Sie sind jetzt 76 Jahre alt, aber ich möchte fragen, ob Ihre Eltern noch leben?
Nein.
Okay, woran sind Ihre Eltern verstorben?
Mein Vater hat einen Schlaganfall und Zuckerkrankheit gestorben. Er war 76 Jahre alt.
Und Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter ist mit 70 Jahren an Herzrhythmstörungen und Darmkrebs gestorben.
Okay. Mein Beileid, Frau Lange. Also, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind, Doktor.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verfüttert und habe vier Kinder.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Drei sind gesund. Eines ist leider verstorben, Doktor. Einen Autounfall.
Mein Beileid, Frau Lange.
Danke schön.
Okay, Sie sind jetzt Rentnerin, aber was machen Sie früher als beruflich gemacht?
Früher war ich als Kochen in Restaurant tätig.
Ja.
Alles klar. Okay, ja. Frau Lange, das waren meine Fragen. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, Doktor.
Oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, was habe ich, Doktor?
Frau Lange, es ist zu früh, etwas genau zu sagen, aber ich vermute, dass Sie eine Darmentzündung haben.
Deswegen werde ich Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen. Dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Wie zum Beispiel die Untersuchung der Unterstärkung.
Was ist die Untersuchung, Doktor? Ist es gefährlich?
Also, das ist ein bildgebendes Verfahren, Frau Lange. Das ist eine schmerzlose und schrallenfrei.
Die Untersuchung. Machen Sie bitte keine Sorgen. Damit können wir die inneren Organe sehen und wir können die Probleme feststellen.
Wie lange dauert diese Untersuchung, Doktor? Es ist lange oder?
Nein, ca. 20 Minuten brauchen wir. Ganz kurz. Und wie gesagt, das ist eine schmerzfreie und schrallenfreie Untersuchung.
Aber ich habe gehört, ich bin nicht schwanger. Meine Nachbarn waren schwanger und Sie haben eine Zonographie durchgeführt, Doktor.
Genau. Also, ja. Ultraschalluntersuchung. Die Ultraschalluntersuchung können wir auch bei schwangeren Frauen durchführen.
Es gibt keine Komplikation mit dieser Untersuchung. Also, wie gesagt, wir können die inneren Organe auch, das Baby, bei dieser Untersuchung sehen, Frau Lange.
Danke schön. Blabla, ich bin kranken, oder?
Ein paar Stunden müssen Sie sicherlich bei uns bleiben, damit wir die Diagnose bestätigen können.
Aber wenn wir etwas Auffälliges finden, kann es auch passieren, dass Sie ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben sollen.
Ok, danke schön. Ich warte auf Sie, Doktor. Danke schön.
Ok, bitte nehmen Sie Platz im Wartezimmer. Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Danke schön. Schönen guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt. Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen und ich würde gerne über Sie berichten.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich? Ja, bitte. Danke schön. Frau Irene Lange ist 76 Jahre alt, 1,76 Meter groß, 71 Kilogramm schwer.
Frau Lange stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit drei Tagen bestehender linkseitiger Unterbauchschmerzen vor.
Der Patientin zufolge sei die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten und mit der Zeit immer geworden.
Die Schmerzen seien stechend, drückend und dumpf und die Schmerzen würden nirgendwo hin austrahlen.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf einer Schmerzkala mit 8 von 10 bewahrtet.
Die Einnahme von Teilzeit-Tabletten hat keine Linderung der Schmerzen gebracht.
Die Patientin berichtete, dass sie ähnliche Beschwerden vor 1,5 Jahren gehabt hat, aber keine bestimmte Diagnose wurde festgestellt.
Sie erwähnte, dass die Schmerzen sich mit der Inklangation verbessern.
Und die Fragen nach Tussis und Dyspnoe wurden verneint.
Bei der Vegetative anamnete seien die Folgenden bekannt.
Pyrexie bis zu 38,9, Axilla Bereich.
Nausea ohne Emesis.
Dysurie.
Schmerzbedingte Inapetens.
Schmerzbedingte Insomnie in Form von Durchschlafstörungen.
Sie sei vorstandig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Covid-Infektionen geimpft.
Anvorerkrankungen nannte sie seit 10 Jahren bestehende Artelehypertonie und seit 2 Jahren bestehenden Diabetes mellitus Typ 2.
Und 1987 diagnostizierte rechtseitige Gonarthose.
Die Patienten nehme im April morgens Lesenidipin auch morgens ein.
Und die Dosierung von diesen Medikamenten sollte geklärt werden.
Sie nehme Metformin 150 mg morgens und Ibuprofen bei Bedarf ein.
Mit 15 Jahren sei bei ihr eine Tonsilektomie durchgeführt worden.
1987 sei sie eine Kreuzbande Riptur rechts zugezogen, die operativ behandelt worden sei.
1994 sei sie wegen einer Adenoma in der rechten Brust operiert worden.
Sie habe Allergie gegen Katzenhaare, die sich durch Phrytus und Exanthem äußert.
Sie sei Ex-Raucherin seit 26 Jahren. Davor habe sie 15 Zigaretten täglich 30 Jahre lang geraucht.
Sie trinke ein Glas Rotwein am Wochenende, Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab sie an, dass der Vater an Apoplex verstorben sei mit 76 Jahren.
Davor habe er an Diabetes mellitus gelitten.
Die Mutter sei mit 70 Jahren an Kolonkarzinon verstorben und sie habe an Herzrhythmusstörungen gelitten.
Sie sei Einzelkind, verwitwet und sie habe vier Kinder.
Ein Kind ist beim Autounfall verstorben. Sie sei Rentnerin, früher habe sie als Köchin gearbeitet.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf Divertikulitis aus, da die Patientin typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Die Patientin leidet unter linkseitiger Unterbauchschmerzen.
Diese Symptome sprechen für eine Pirexie bis 38,9, Nausea und Dysurie.
Diese Symptome sprechen für eine Divertikulitis.
Als differential Diagnosen kommen Handwerkinfektionen und Adnexitis und Ovariatrosion in Betracht.
Um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zunächst bei der Patientin die Vitaparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Hautfarbeveränderungen, geschwollene Lymphknoten, Druckschmerzen, Abwehrspannung, Loslassschmerzen vorhanden sind.
Zusätzlich ist eine Laborntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnose zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild, CAP, BSG, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Elektrolyten bestimmen lassen.
Und ich würde auch eine Urinstatus und Urinkultur bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine Röntgen des Abdomens durchführen, um die mögliche Perforation auszuschließen.
Darüber hinaus würde ich eine Abdominal Sonographie durchführen, um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen und andere mögliche Pathologien auszuschließen.
Danach würde ich eine CT des Abdomens durchführen, um die genauen Pathologien zu beurteilen.
Und würde ich eine Dopplex Sonographie durchführen, um eine Ovarian Torsion auszuschließen.
Sollte sich die Verdacht Diagnose bestätigen, würde ich die Patientin stationär aufnehmen.
Und ich würde der Patientin einen venösen Zugang legen.
Und ich würde Analgetika, Antiemetika, Spasmolytika, Antibiotika verabreichen.
Und danach würde ich ein chirurgisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie der Patientin zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren, Herr Oberarzt.
Herr Kollegen, Sie haben gesagt, ich würde eine Abdomen Sonographie durchführen. Welche Zeichen erwarten Sie in der Abdomen Sonographie?
Was verursacht die Vertikulitis im Darm?
Ich würde sagen, dass es eine linksseitige Apendicitis ist. Die Symptome dieser zwei Krankheiten sind sehr ähnlich.
Bei der Apendicitis sehen wir eine Entzündung mit dem Blinddarm und sechseitige Unterbauchschmerzen und Fieber und Nausea.
Bei der Divertikulitis sehen wir eine entzündliche Divertikel, linksseitige Unterbauchschmerzen, Fieber und Nausea.
Sehr ähnliche Symptome, aber sehr andere Seiten der Abdomen Schmerzen, Herr Oberarzt.
Was verursacht die Divertikulitis?
Also vielleicht eine fremde Körper, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Perforation, Abscess, Pistel, Garper Schloss.
Meinen Sie Komplikationen?
Ja, wir können bei der Divertikulitis eine Perforation, Abscess, Pistel feststellen.
Nach der Akutbehandlung empfehlen Sie den Patienten Koloskopie?
Nein, Koloskopie ist eine Kontraindikation bei akuter Divertikulitis.
Ich meine nach der Akutbehandlung oder Gasenbehandlung.
Okay, ja, nach der Behandlung, wenn die Situation der Patienten besser ist, können wir eine Koloskopie machen, um die genaue Pathologie zu beurteilen.
Braucht der Patient eine Operation?
Wenn es Komplikationen wie zum Beispiel Perforation, Abscess oder Pistel gibt, können wir eine Operation durchführen.
Sonst braucht der Patient keine Operation.
Welche Operation führen Sie durch?
Besonders bei der Perforation sollen wir eine offene Operation durchführen.
Empfehlen Sie den Patienten eine Peroskopische Operation?
Normalerweise machen wir keine Operation bei dieser Krankheit ohne Komplikationen.
Aber bei der Perforation sollen wir sicherlich eine offene Operation durchführen.
Aber mit dem Abscess oder Pistel können wir vielleicht auch eine Offene Operation durchführen.
Okay.
Welche anderen Krankheiten verursacht linksseitige Abdominal Schmerzen?
Ja, linksseitige Unterabdominal Schmerzen können wir über Distortion, Adnexitis bei den Frauen.
Und wir können auch Milzprobleme mit der linksseitigen Oberbauchschmerzen feststellen.
Und wir können auch Koloncarcinomen feststellen mit linksseitigen Unterbauchschmerzen.
Kolitis ulcerosa, Morbus Crohn, Urolithiasis und linksseitige Leistenbrüche.
Herr Kollegen, empfehlen Sie in diesem Fall eine CT des Abdomens des Patienten?
Ja, wir können eine CT des Abdomens durchführen um die Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen mit Kontrast mittel.
Ja, mit Kontrast mittel ist sehr wichtig. Würden Sie in diesem Fall eine MRT des Abdomens?
Also wir können die genaue Pathologie bei der CT-Untersuchung feststellen. Aber ich werde das nicht nötig, Herr Arzt.
Normalerweise würden Sie keine MRT des Abdomens in diesem Fall empfehlen.
Weil wenn der Patient Komplikation hat, müssen wir schnell die Diagnose stellen.
Schnell die Diagnose mit CT des Abdomens.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall eine RSP durchführen?
Nein, wir sollen RSP für die Pathologien über Gallenblasengänge und Pankreasgangs.
Bei diesem Fall sollen wir keine RSP durchführen, Herr Arzt.
Was empfehlen Sie den Patienten nach der Behandlung?
Ja, ich würde die Patienten Lebensstilveränderungen empfehlen. Sie seien Ex-Rauchhörer.
Sie trinken kein Alkohol regelmäßig. Gewichtsprobleme hat sie nicht.
Also alles in Ordnung bei diesen Patienten. Aber sie sollen regelmäßig ihren Hausarzt besuchen nach der Behandlung.
Sonst habe ich keine Idee.
Empfehlen Sie den Patienten Ernährungsumstellung?
Ja, die Patienten sollen ...
Ich habe den Namen vergessen, Herr Arzt.
Ja, ich auch.
Stopp, Stopp, Stopp.
Stoppweichende Ernährung.
Ich bin ja nicht sicher.
Also auch die Lieferung?
Ja, genau.
Aber man muss es auch lernen. Vielleicht werden sie fragen.
Das stimmt.
Herr Kollegen, empfehlen Sie den Patienten viel Beweglichkeit?
Die Patientin ist 76 Jahre alt. Nicht viel Beweglichkeit, aber sie kann regelmäßig bewegen.
Sie leidet unter alterlichem Platoni, Diabetes mellitus.
Deswegen empfehle ich ihr regelmäßig Bewegung, aber nicht zu viel, glaube ich.
Ja, regelmäßig Beweglichkeit ist wichtig in diesem Fall. Würden Sie in diesem Fall Ambulat behandeln?
Nein, die Patientin hat Fieber bis zu 38,9. Wir sollen eine IV-Antibiotik verabreichen.
Und Sie haben schon vergessen, diese Patientin hat auch Dysurie.
Und ich glaube, es gibt auch eine handwerkliche Infektion. Eine komplizierte Infektion.
Deswegen sollen wir die Patientin tatsächlich aufnehmen.
Und sie ist 76 Jahre alt. Deswegen wäre es besser, im Krankenhaus zu bleiben.
Meinen Sie als differential Diagnose auch, denken wir, Pioleonephritis oder Harnweginfektionen?
Ja, das stimmt. Wir sollen auch eine Therapie gegen Harnweginfektionen anordnen, Herr Oberst.
Also Ciprophyloxacin und Methanidazol wäre eine gute Möglichkeit bei dieser Patientin, glaube ich.
Ok, vielen Dank, Herr Kollegen. Bitte gehen Sie in unser Impfadvisor und nehmen Sie Ihre Certificate.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg für Ihr Arbeitsweg.
Vielen Dank für diese sehr angenehme Art und Sprache, Herr Oberst. Vielen Dank.